oh
that's a friggin cg rock bro
they're doing some pretty nuts stuff
here with the jet ski the jet ski
effects are incredible
what's he getting no what's he gonna do
[Applause]
this video is brought to you by
microcenter stick around to the end to
figure out how you can get a 32 gigabyte
flash drive and micro sd card for free
i did that to a guy last week like for
[Music]
real
[Music]
hey what's up everybody we're back
bollywood episode
six we're here to react to bollywood
clips you know it because the title says
bollywood i'm here
joined by my favorite friends wren and
sam
bollywood films and indian cinema that
region of the world in general produces
some of the best
films you've ever seen they define
physics gravity
the rules of mankind they break every
film rule that exists
and then they smash them on the ground
and it's it's beautiful
let's take a look at some of those
awesome scenes right now
[Music]
so we we checked out doom 2 the sequence
where he like went into the manhole and
came up as a rollerblade man
oh that was doom 2. and then they
proceeded to like roller skate down the
highway
yeah so he's back in room 3.
what's he gonna do he's cornered
bad guys on one side cops on the other
she
tata for now turbo man
what the that's he's gonna have let's
get into like impossible
[Music]
not only not only does he jump the
bridge
he doesn't freak he's doing a backflip
he does a back flip
it's the only way he can make it but
wait a second
[Music]
oh but hold on
it's wait that's not nearby
from the beginning
they're doing some pretty nuts stuff
here with the jet ski and the bridge
jump
which is like the center piece of this
whole sequence right here
so the bridge is obviously raised for
real but any of these shots here like
these wide angle shots with the bike
on the bridge fully like tilted up it's
100 seasons cg yeah they're throwing in
a cg bike
cg bike sees you smoke but there's a
there's one moment here where it
instantly becomes oh this is all cg and
it's this right here
that shot yeah yeah it's like jarringly
cg and i think it's because the
background is just uniformly out of
focus
like the bottom of the bridge and the
top of the bridge are the same out of
focus
it's straight up just the previous shot
the wide they took that still image
scaled it up and threw some uh blur on
it you're right dude
like that shot's sweet that shot is
sweet where you see like the building in
the distance that one actually looks
more realistic
the underside of that bike it's so shiny
and uniform like it needs
it needs like oil and like gunk to like
mat up that shine there's no surface
there's no
surface imperfections it's like way too
clean it's like
product reveals sort of rendering i mean
i think actually with the imperfections
this would
look very realistic because you look at
the lighting and the render quality on
everything it's like
excellent but then it doesn't matter
because you're instantly like what it's
a transforming motorcycle what's it
gonna do
the jet ski effects are incredible holy
[ __ ]
yeah wow dude freaking rotoing water
they rode water you have to be so like
at peace with yourself and zen to
rotoscope water
it's like cleaning your floor with a
toothbrush man
[Music]
here we go get ready
[Music]
did he grab his nuts and fling them look
at this dude's kick in the denim pants
[Music]
remember that scene that you just saw
let's take a look at it again
in slow motion
all right look i want you guys to tell
me what
american movie true lies what american
await watchmen
no what um
we can write draw now fracture
you guys are telling me you don't know
exactly what scene this is exactly
last samurai oh yes yes last samurai
the same exact premise they go back and
they just like play in slo-mo
the same exact acting the director
showed him a clip of tom
cruise and he's like dude the same thing
he's like
there's samurai swords in it they even
cut off an arm
anyway that's not the point of why i
brought that clip up it's just because i
thought the clip was kind of janky so i
wanted to show you guys
the editing was so choppy i know it's
like they
literally edited the entire slow motion
piece and just took the entire thing and
like
sped it up to like 1 000 speed and
dropped it in first
yeah i get taken vibes yeah where it's
just like really poor editing or because
i mean look i mean this guy i know he's
a cool
big star and all but you know he's you
know he's middle-aged he's got a little
chub on him
they're making him look as good as
possible
[Music]
oh hey guess what i'm doing a video
about balloons remember the movie up
well i'm doing a whole video about how
many balloons would really be needed to
lift the house from up it's pretty sweet
i go into all kinds of cool detail
including theoretical balloon technology
check it out tomorrow because it's
coming out tomorrow but for now finish
watching our react episode
cause india is cool bollywood
oh snap dude okay spider i bet
20 dollars on a secret operative named
spider
that's a freaking cg rock bro
looks like a freaking meatball
is that whole shot cg yeah that whole
shots the entire shot is cg
full siege full siege we're going full
siege boys
this is real that's a real shock but
watch out the color space when it comes
to the gamut of the whole shot shifts i
have noticed how sometimes like a lot of
these
simulations they have like a very
distinct look where they actually look
like puzzle pieces like someone like
imagine taking a like a puzzle and then
just like hitting it from the underside
all the pieces are kind of uniformly
uniform yes
that makes sense yeah like there's not
like smaller chunks and then larger
chunks
they're all just kind of the same
what's he gonna do no what's he what's
he's gonna do all right pause pause pop
pop pop all right so we got a cg rock
going through our city
what do you do i know exactly what he's
gonna do he's gonna hop in
to a to an industrial sized vehicle he's
going to lower the back of it
and the the boulder is going to ramp
over like he's going to drift the truck
in front of a bunch of like school kids
and he's going to like
lower the back of the dump truck and
it's gonna launch off and into like a
lake or something
i cannot come up with anything better
than that that's gotta be the way it
goes
wait he's right he just got in the truck
oh it's an 18-wheeler okay
oh what's he getting
what's he gonna do
or is it unstoppable is it unstoppable
or no jump
he does save a child
he did use an industrial vehicle it
almost became a ramp he kind of drifted
it's just the rock stopped before it
could go flying through the air
dang look that's we got seven out of ten
seven out of ten
some pretty good crack effects yeah
that's that's pretty legit
whoa whoa that dude
[Applause]
the the world's lightest child
wow what a shot yeah whoa okay that
that's that's a real set dropping down
these are some really complex shots i
know come
on oh
they lost a few
who's this guy who could this guy the
mastermind
[Laughter]
see he just climbs up risk life and limp
the level transfer when you slam them
hard enough and it changes the level
oh
they're the surprises
how's this guy gonna die are we gonna
take bets
how is this guy gonna die how do you
guys think this guy's gonna die he's
gonna tear him in two pieces
and then throw him into a pit okay he's
gonna fall backwards and get himself
impaled on rebar
gonna say that dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's gonna be impaling
actually i'm throwing in my money on
that one my .001 bitcoins
towards impaling
okay oh wait we got rebar and a pit oh
wait
the uppercut oh no oh
just as i was starting to doubt if that
was actually going to happen it totally
delivered guys are we psychic like
we have gotten so good at this
so so first and foremost this whole
scene the first half of it's just
stuff cracking and it's really really
well done and i'm trying to figure out
if they're
basically doing like full cg
replacements of
these structures or if they're basically
just doing
a projection map where you basically
take a frame of your image
and project it onto like some cg objects
from the camera's perspective
so that way your footage basically
matches perfectly and you're not trying
to like composite a fully
fake object it's an object that has the
textures that are in your actual frame
but what about this shot look at that
ground there that's if this is cg that's
really well done
like look at how like the ground
actually is pulling away that kind of
makes me think that it's actually a
practical set there i know that they did
have some practical
elements here a lot a lot of this was
actually practical they did some really
cool stuff and they would just
recreate this like destructive hospital
look in 3d that just gets
put onto the green screen in the
background so even though it looks like
they're five stories above the bottom of
this hole they're really just like half
a story exactly yeah
you know it's so funny like some of
these shots the rendering quality isn't
that good like you can tell it's cg but
then a lot of this stuff is like
flawless rendering
this is definitely houdini houdini is an
effects program
for high level simulations used in the
visual effects industry
you can do most of this stuff in cinema
4d but houdini just has a better
like pipeline for like the complex sort
of thing like this it's just
houdini's incredibly hard to learn yeah
i think it's like a
really nice mix of practical and visual
here i think it's the smoke the smoke
kind of gives it away and there's some
stuff like with rubble falling that
there's like no motion blur on the
falling rubble inside i noticed that too
yeah like right when the destruction
starts really happening like there's
like a
spray of a bunch of rubble falling down
but yeah i definitely think the
the actual like smoke sims are where
it's like the weakest and by smoke i
mean like dust any of the volumetric
uh particulates in the air a little on
the weak side just because they're not
they look blurry yeah they're blurry
they're a little too fuzzy
so guys it's getting harder and harder
for us to top ourselves when it comes to
bollywood vfx
we need crazier bollywood vfx shots so
if you guys
have any please leave a comment down
below we'll take a look at them and
they'll be on the next episode of vfxr's
react bollywood
all right now that all that stuff is out
of the way yeah that was a good time
you're here for the free 32 gigabyte
flash drives and micro sd's i know so
shout out to our sponsor micro center
for making that possible let me tell you
a little bit about them
get the best prices and best selection
on pc components and technology at any
one of microcenter's
25 locations across the united states
[Music]
join the micro center community to give
and receive advice on pc hardware
and parts selection and to discuss tech
with other enthusiasts
check out the micro center custom pc
builder to spec out the best pc
at your price point
check the links in the description to
visit micro center and enter your email
for a free
32 gigabyte flash drive and 32 gigabyte
micro sd card
[Music]
they're not playing around here guys
they're giving away free data
so check out the link it's in the
description oh
boy i have a headache from laughing so
hard my neck hurts from laughing so hard
yeah that was a good time
that was more fun just to watch this
stuff than to break down the effects
this time
these are the hardest clips to break
down because they are so
freaking entertaining that we forget
we're supposed to be breaking the vfx
down we just start watching the dang
scene
so once again thanks for watching
subscribe like blah blah hit the b hit
every button you see below this video
give it a good smack for us
even smack your keyboard in the comments
section a little bit does it can be
gibberish
but thanks for watching stay tuned for
another one of these in the future